we're learning president Trump's former
campaign chairman was wired tapped by
the federal government during the
campaign and election CBS News has
confirmed that the FBI was conducted
secret surveillance was conducting
rather secret surveillance on Paul
Manafort over concerns about his
contacts with Russian operatives
evidence from the wiretaps has become
part of Special Counsel Robert Miller's
investigation into Russian meddling in
the u.s. election Jeff Pegues is in
Washington with how this could impact
that investigation Jeff good morning
good morning CBS News has confirmed that
the FBI obtained foreign intelligence
surveillance warrants and was tracking
Paul manna for its alleged contacts with
Russian operatives it is yet another
sign that the former Trump campaign
chairman has been at the center of the
Russian investigation for at least the
last year the surveillance of Paul
Manafort included his time as Trump
campaign chairman CBS News has confirmed
that man aboard was targeted over
concerns he was communicating with
Russian operatives who wanted to
influence the 2016 election
investigators have multiple wiretap
conversations between Manafort and
Russian individuals the intercepts were
part of a wide-ranging FBI
counterintelligence operation during the
campaign Trump associates including
manna fort were dogged by questions of
suspected ties with Russia mr. Trump has
no financial relationships with any
Russian oligarchs that's what he said
and that's what I said that's the FBI
surveillance is now part of Special
Counsel Robert Muller's investigation
into whether the Trump campaign
conspired with the Russians manna Ford
has faced the most intense scrutiny to
date the New York Times reports Muller
conducted a raid on manna Ford's home in
July in Virginia federal agents picked
the lock on his front door while he was
asleep confiscating a number of items
he's become more famous than me it's all
part of a broad investigation which
includes president Trump's firing of FBI
director James Comey and the actions of
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn man affords representatives have
not commented on these latest reports
but in the
past they have maintained that he has
done nothing illegal today another Trump
associate will be under scrutiny Michael
Cohen who calls himself the president's
personal attorney will face questioning
from the Senate Intelligence Committee
on Capitol Hill Charlie thanks Jeff